[Music]
how fair is the situation in Germany who
are the wealthy and who lives from
paycheck to paycheck
most Germans earn regular wages or a
salary they earn enough to make a living
but they can't set much aside the
average German worker earns around 2,500
euros a month
gross that goes to paying taxes and
living expenses over the past 13 years
wages have increased by 28 percent but
income from investment has increased
more than twice that rate that's in part
because income taxes are much higher
than taxes on assets
remanent in germany we have the strange
situation that investment income is
taxed at a flat rate of 25% the income
tax goes up to 42% and more that's not
fair
those who just sit on their sofa and
study their account statements pay much
less taxes than those who work hard for
their money the best oil let's women huh
albeit the wealth gap in Germany is
growing many people earn a good living
but they can't manage to save families
especially the average household with
one or two children has a net income of
about 2900 euros a month including state
subsidies an average family spends
around 300 euros a month on food their
largest budget item is rent and
utilities at around 700 years a month
another 300 years goes to transportation
leisure activities including Culture and
sports cost another 250 euros then
there's clothing health and childcare
expenses when you figure in all those
costs the average family has only about
300 euros a month left over for savings
and retirement
this mantra of a number of factors go
into converting income from work into
assets at first you have to limit
consumption some people can't do that
and need their entire income for daily
expenses but interest rates are almost
zero right now which is putting a dent
in many people's retirement savings
linked to money is for silicon here in
Stoughton poverty among the elderly is
likely to rise for people without assets
statutory pensions are unlikely to cover
living expenses the average pension is
700 euros a month and many women get
only half that over the past 10 years
the risk of poverty and Germany has
increased by 40 percent that's despite
the fact that Germany is actually home
to plenty of wealth more than 2 billion
euros a year get passed on in
inheritance the tax rate there is just 2
percent another reason why many experts
say Germany needs to become more
equitable